foreign
Michigan hi Bonita how are you
I'm pretty good how about you better
than I deserve what's up
um so
I've been listening to you for a few
months now and I've been trying to pay
off this a little bit of debt I have and
as well I got my boyfriend listening to
you in pain we paid his bed off and
everything and things have been going
good but then I um you know I'm taking a
gap Year from school this year I'm in
college and yesterday I found out that I
didn't unenroll from the classes
in time like I thought I did and now I'm
on the hook for about 10 grand
that I need to pay
um that I wasn't expecting to pay
and I feel like it just kind of put a
wrench in my plans uh that's a lot of
money for me and I just I don't know I
don't really know what I would go down
and meet with the registrar's office
and let them know exactly what you did
and you say I
had a lot going on and I screwed up and
I didn't withdraw from these classes I
never attended these classes I haven't
been a student here
can you help me out I don't have ten
thousand dollars to write you a check
right now
and I will tell you I've worked at
universities that would say absolutely
we'll take care of you and I've worked
at universities that would say sorry we
have to go by the policy
I'll also tell you that the reason I'm
in this seat right now
is because I was taking a master's level
counseling class as an administrator and
I registered for that class like in
April it was a summer class I completely
forgot about it
and I went to register for the fall
classes I was just taking a class here
and there and I had an F on my
transcript so I called the I emailed the
professor and said hey I never went to
the class I got an F okay we know you
didn't and she goes no you didn't show
up to my class you got an F
then I went up across campus and I said
hey I can't have an F on my transcript
and she said I will take care of this
but you have to go to my child play
therapy class at that time I would
rather set myself on fire than go to a
child's play therapy class and I went
and then we ended up
um she said what are you doing getting a
master's degree and you get a degree and
she ended up being the reason I'm in
Nashville Tennessee so I tell you that
to tell you this
if you made a mistake own the mistake
somebody might help you out and it may
be the best thing that ever happened to
you and it may be that you just got to
pay 10 000 bucks and move on I sure hope
you don't but uh in person
Tick Tock DM
or whatever the crap Tic Tac or whatever
you don't just go in there in person sit
down like a human and don't blame them
blame yourself take all the ownership
yeah humble what we used to call hat in
hand
I messed up please give me mercy I'm
begging for mercy I am here to fall
before your desk and ask for Mercy
that's right and um I goofed up by three
days or five days or whatever I thought
I did it properly I was stressed out I'm
taking a gap year because I'm broke and
I'm certainly so too broke to pay ten
thousand dollars and so please help me
one other loophole might be can you at
least give me incompletes on these
grades so I can take them again
when I get done with my Gap Year and
that may be a way not to get your money
back but to preserve so you have to pay
for those classes twice that might be
something you can do also
but hopefully it'll give you your money
back
you can probably get that
hopefully they'll just
say yeah we deal with college age people
and sometimes they mess up